العالم في حالة توتر هذا الصباح حيث
يواصل الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حشد القوات والمعدات
بالقرب من حدوده مع أوكرانيا
يقول المسؤولون الأمريكيون إنهم ما زالوا
ملتزمين بالخيارات الدبلوماسية ، لكن وفقًا
لآخر تقييم استخباراتي
أمريكي ، تمتلك روسيا الآن ما يقرب من 75 من قواتها
التقليدية.  تم وضع القوات هناك
على الحدود ، لذلك دعونا
نتجول بالضبط مع
اللواء جيمس سبايدر ماركس
محللنا العسكري في سي إن إن ورئيس
الإستراتيجية الجيوسياسية
والأوراق المالية في الأكاديمية ، حسنًا ، هل يمكنك فقط معرفة
أين كان قد وضع كل شيء  لقد جمعت هذه
القوات
جيدًا ، دعنا نلقي نظرة عليها
وقبل كل شيء دعونا نأخذها من
منظور بوتين إذا كان بإمكاننا
عضو الناتو العضو في الناتو ،
وهذا ما بدأ كل هذا هو
حركة الناتو هذه إلى
الشرق وهذا هو الرأي الذي قاله بوتين
ما يثير قلقه ، فما تراه
هو منشآت يتم
احتلالها بشكل روتيني من قبل القوات الروسية بالموقع
الأحمر  التي تراها على الخريطة هنا
هي المكان الذي تجري فيه التدريبات
وهذا هو المكان الذي تم فيه وضع بوتين والرئيس
لوكاتشينكو في نهاية هذا الأسبوع
معًا
لمراقبة التدريبات ، لذا فقد
انتشر ليشمل القوات الموجودة هنا في
شبه جزيرة القرم
والتي نعلم جميعًا أنه قام بها في عام 2014  . لذلك فإن هذا
يمثل تهديدًا لا يُصدق من الواضح أن
أوكرانيا محاطة من ثلاث جهات ،
وهذا ما يثير قلق الجميع بشكل لا يُصدق
كما ينبغي أن
يكون الأمر قانونيًا ويتعلق بالحركة إلى أين
تتجه القوات ، فما هي
صور الأقمار الصناعية الجديدة التي تظهر أننا
رأينا نعم بريانا  اسمحوا لي أن أريكم أن
إحدى قطع الصور التي
ظهرت للتو في هذا هي موقع دبابة
ولكنك ترى أيضًا دبابات
ومركبات دعم والتي ستكون
ناقلات جنود مدرعة للتزود بالوقود لرجال المشاة
ومن الواضح أن اليهود الروس
يستخدمون  جنود المشاة ثم
الدبابات لدعم ما يختلف
عن كيفية استخدام الولايات المتحدة له حيث
نريد استغلاله بدروعنا.
يتم استخدام anks ثم المشاة
بشكل مناسب للقيام ببعض
الأعمال الدقيقة حقًا ، لذا فإن ما تراه
بهذه الصورة هو مؤشر على
احتمال كبير جدًا أن أقول كتيبة
أو ربما شركة داخل كتيبة
مما يعني وجود قوات أخرى  التي
تقع خارج نطاق هذه القطعة من
الصور الموجودة في مواقع مباشرة
وجاهزة للهجوم مرة أخرى ، ما لا نعرفه
أعنيه أبعد من ذلك ، إنه أمر مخيف
ولكن ما لا نعرفه هو قدرة
ما لا نعرفه هو ما إذا
كانت القاعدة  هو أو أن المهمة هي
الذهاب أو الاستمرار في الاحتفاظ بما لدينا